[موسيقى]
الميه اللي بتسيل منه الغازات اللي بتطلع
من هذا من هذا المكان المياه اللي بتنزل
البلاستيك النايلون اللي بطير كتل حلالنا
اذانا الريحه في الليل ما بنقدر ننام منها
في عنا اولاد مرضاء من هذا الاشي دائما
الاولاد مرشحين وعندهم ازمات وفي ناس مرض
وصابوا يعني مرض السرطان الله يشافي
الجميع لكن هذا المكب هو يعرف بالنسبه انك
مكرهه مكرهه صحيه لجميع المنطقه مش بس عنا
[موسيقى]
وهذا المكب حيضل لمئه سنه قادمه لا يصلح
للاستخدام على الاطلاق هندسيا ممنوع
استخدامه
وممنوع البناء عليه واذا بدنا نرجع
نستخدمه ونعيد استصلاح هنحتاجه 100 سنه
لغايه ما الماده العضويه تتحلل ونتاكد انه
ما في غازات بتطلع في المكان واللي هي
ممكن تحصى يحدث انفجار نتيجه انحباس
الغازات وتشكل الضغط
[موسيقى]
كم النفايات تم اغلاقه امام المجمعات
الفلسطينيه وبقي شغال لخدمه معالق ادومي
والمنطقه الصناعيه اللي هي الخانه الاحمر
تقريبا بيوصل مكب النفايات ما يعادل بين
الالف وخمسميه الى 1800 طن ومرشح انه هو
يرتفع وتزيد هذه النسبه الى الفين طن
يوميا الان 70% الى 80% من هاي النفايات
هي النفايات قابله لاعاده التحلل يعني
مواد عضويه كل كيلوغرام من الماده العضويه
بيعطينا تقريبا من خمسه سته الى سته لتر
من الغازات الدفيئه هذا المكان انشا عام
1980 1981 بدون ما يعملوا له عمليه
اللاينج اللي هي التغطيه للار
والاخطر من ذلك ما وضعوا برك لجمع ومعالجه
المياه الناشئه عن تحلل الماده العضويه
انما تركوها تروح في الواد
[موسيقى]